ومن جهه ثانيه تتواصل موجات النزوح من
السودان حيث يشهد معبر ارقين على الحدود
السودانيه المصريه حركه النشطه للفرينه من
السودان الى مصر بسبب مواجهات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه وقال مدير
معبر ارقين احمد فضلي ان عدد الذين عبروا
منذ بدء المواجهات يقدر بنحو اثني عشر الف
شخص من السودانيين ورعايا دول اجنبيه
موضحا ان استثناءات خاصه للمسافرين طبقت
في المعبر بسبب ظروف الحرب منها تمديد
صلاحيه جوازات السفر بالتعاون مع
الحكومتين المصريه والسودانيه
معنى من معبر ارقينا على الحدود السودانيه
المصريه مراسل الجزيره حسن رزاق اثنا عشر
الفا مروا اذا من هذا المعبر
وتسهيلات فيما يتعلق بالجوازات ما هي
الاجراءات الاخرى المتخذه وكيف هي الاجواء
عند هذا المعبر
بالفعل زين طبعا منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر
وصلت الى هنا اكثر من ست باصات قادمه من
الخرطوم قاطعه مسافه تقارب الف كيلو متر
بالباصات والتي وصلت فجرا وتنتظر حتى
الثانيه عشره ظهرا بالتوقيت المحلي لفتح
المعبر الان هو المعبر خالي من المسافرين
الذين عبروا خلال اكثر من ساعه كامله الى
الى ميناء عرقين المصري حيث سوف يتجهون من
هناك الى محطات محطه كركر ومنها الى مدينه
اسوان في مسافه تمتد حوالي خمس ساعات طبعا
هذا المعبر زين هو احد المعابر المهمه على
الحدود بين السودان وجمهوريه مصر العربيه
حيث هناك ايضا معبر اخر معبر اشكيت وهذا
ايضا معبر لكن هذا المعبر غالبا ما ياتي
اليه
السودانيين او النساء والاطفال وكبار السن
باعتبار انهم لا يحتاجون الى تاشيره مسبقه
الدخول الى جمهوريه مصر عكسها معبر اشكيت
حيث هناك توجد قنصليه مصريه في مدينه حلفا
والتي تبعد من معبر اشكاد حوالي 30 كيلو
متر حيث من يحتاجون الى الحصول على تاشيره
مسبقه لابد ان يذهبوا هناك للحصول على
تاشيره ومن ثم يتوجهون الى معبر اشكيت منه
الى محطه سما
بالقرب من القاهره للدخول على اي حال زين
طبعا هذا المعبر شهد الفتره الماضي اقتضاض
كبير من قبل المسافرين وايضا من قبل
العابرين الفارين من جحيم المعارك
المحتدمه في الخرطوم حيث قال لنا مدير
المعبر أنا اكثر من 420 باص عبروا في
الفتره الماضيه بمعدل ركاب في كل باص ما
بين 35 الى 40 وبالتالي هذا عدد كبير جدا
بالنسبه للطاقه الاستيعابيه لهذا المعبر
الصغير الذي كان في غالبه مخصص للبضائع
الاستهلاكيه لكن بالنسبه للركاب لم ياتي
هذا العدد كبير الا مع وصول او مع استمرار
المواجهات العسكريه الكثير من التسهيلات
قدمت بالتنسيق بين الحكومتين المصريه
والسودانيه منها تمديد صلاحيه جواز السفر
حيث كان الكثير من الذين قدموا جوازاتهم
منتهيه وتم تمديدها لمده سته اشهر
بالتنسيق ما بين الدولتين ايضا المواليد
الذين لم يتم استخراج جوازات لهم تم
اضافتها الى جوازات الامه الاب لتسهيل
سفرهم الى مصر ايضا الذين فقدوا جوازاتهم
وارقام واوراق ثبتهم تم استصدار لهم وثيقه
سفر مؤقته فقط لكبار السن او للاطفال او
للنساء باعتبار انهم لا يحتاجون الى
تاشيره لكن من يحتاج الى تاشيره يحتاج الى
استصدار جواز وهذه طبعا اجراءات معقده علي
حال زين هذا المعبر حاليا نشهد خفه في
الحركه باعتبار ان الثقل كله الان في معبر
سكيت نعم زين
شكرا جزيلا لك حسن رزاق مراسل الجزيره من
معبر ارقين على الحدود المصريه السودانيه